ci sarà da incazzarsi è la tutti ragazzi
venuti questo video sono fa vj oggi sono
con questa roba qua perché fa un freddo
bestia siamo tornati dopo non mi ricordo
neanche quanti anni su l'one ap techeye
che è un gioco di quelli che ti fanno
girare le palle che la metà basta ho
deciso di riportarlo sul canale perché
era da una vita che non perché non
provavo incazzature serie non è vero che
ho giocato a getting over it
devo venire qua no credetemi ragazzi è
veramente molto più difficile di quanto
porca di novak è molto più difficili
quanto possiate pensare a ma si può
andar lì sopra non me lo ricordavo così
sono sincero lo ricordava un po più
allora ragazzi per forza vacca sono
morto prima così per chi non lo
conoscesse allora vi spiego e questo è
il gioco di questo bambino che non è
impossibile ragazza ve lo giuro che già
è già stato un casino fare questo e da
una vita e mezza che non gioco a sta
roba
non mi ricordo assolutamente niente ma
il nulla più assoluto quindi vado a culo
perché per adesso sta andando bene
incredibilmente aiuto ok
a non ti mandava giù perfetto va bene
siamo arrivati qua e ovviamente se vuoi
io riparto di nuovo da zero perché i
salvataggi in questo gioco si prendono
una volta ogni anno e solo fare quindi
per arrivare al salvataggio lo saltare
ma non me lo sarei mai
no mi spiegate come faccio a fare questa
roba
ogni volta devo iniziare da zero ma se
sei serio se non ho fatto il bravo
ragazzo aveva voluto punirmi per questo
no ma come dovrei far la sua parte non
mi ricordo assolutamente mai nella vita
d1 doc ero lì madonna e non ce l'ho
fatta
se i premi per il culo anche con gli
assoli di chitarra poi che vada bene fai
che vada bene
no non è vero non mi ricordo quanto ci
ho messo quattro anni fa o quando ci ho
giocato non mi ricordo mi ricordo però
che ci ho messo tanto e vi darò uno
scoop
mi ricordo che mi hanno messo a montare
questo video a mezzanotte
avrò finito di montarlo tipo alle 4 del
mattino e alle 7 sono andato a scuola
pensate con che voglia sono andato a
scuola i nonni è possibile una gran con
che voglia ero andato a scuola che sono
shopinn anche la voglia di vivere
calmi zitti avevo ripassare un attimo i
versi del vangelo a posto
falconi novacco morta morta morta che
fastidio
no ragazzi al bene anche se se vado
accendere un cero ce ne ho paura ad
andare a dormire su sei stupido
step di monco niente raga niente magagne
no magagna va ai ragazzi dai dai
come cosa succhiami le guarda non lo
dico perché sono in family friendly però
prendilo ma non lo prende come faccia a
prenderlo o eccolo quindi adesso se
muoio schiaccia ogni volta che ho paura
magari poi vado avanti intorno
all'inizio cosa sa qualcosa a vado
devo pregare gesù bene aiuta vince su è
uno ok
e vabbè fino a qua ci siamo arrivati là
che già un traguardo e non ci arrivo
dopo però un casino vediamo se riesco a
farlo bene
e salta in avanti o lo schiaccio to
salti io schiaccio come tua madre e tu
salti come tua madre bene no porcari una
rocca morta come avevo fatto una volta
ma allora sei stupido nell'anima di
avere dei problemi al cervello non me lo
devi spiegare perché in questo momento
non capisco ok datemi un altro
salvataggio vi prego non so che dovevo
fare qua non mi ricordo non mi ricordo
cosa vuoi che faccia già arrivare di
nuovo lì è un casino incredibile cosa
devo fare qua spiega mi di melo parla
cosa aiuto o cosa fa cosas per parla di
te non lo so ora che non capisco mi
acceca non capisco dove ci sarà un
qualcosa di invisibile che non vedo ma
non posso continuare così a lanciarmi
nel vuoto tipo al akhbar a eva morta
ma salta o una vecchia vj day del di
ictus
non è vero la canon è vero ma donna non
è vero ma donna no kat
no no no no gesù
allora qua sopra
ma che cosa devo fare della mia vita ho
ringraziamo a cristo ma è questo l'avevo
immaginato più o meno è questa io devo
morire milioni di volte per capire come
mi sono salvato per capire dove la roba
cioè non so se vi rendete conto è non so
dove devo andare la cava da culo
ho sbattuto contro qualcosa non ho
capito cosa ma va bene ho appena
scoperto una roba veramente brutta
ragazzi a parte il fatto che il costo è
qui problema non è questo il problema
adesso arriva era la strada sbagliata
non serve a niente perché devo tornare
indietro wow che gioco meraviglioso
allora la strada giusta
nel caso ve lo stesse chiedendo è questa
se io dovevo salire su non fatemi
parlare devo salire su questo schifo qui
ad andare di sopra io come faccia come
me lo ricordavo mai nella vita spiega
nei passati 800 anni e millemila capelli
da quella volta lì no vabbè ma è
impossibile come avevo fatto fare sta
roba
avrei già concluso il video
cosa che molto probabilmente farò quanto
ci vuole per arrivare al prossimo no no
non adesso no adesso i tasti permanenti
windows di merda windows
perché i tasti permanenti windows quando
non servono
succhia me ne mandi ancora definita
finito best a parte un casino
tanto per cambiare
quest'anno siamo ai limiti della
denuncia quarta
si vabbè ma mi prendete prima cosa ma
non è mai ma va a cagare vabbè ma vai a
morire
spiegami cioè non ha veramente il senso
di esistere ma porco demonio morto
non è vero non è vero alla cieca pure lo
faccio ormai talmente tante volte ho
fatto sta parte marca vacca c'è una
versione di questo gioco dove i
salvataggi di fai tu ragazzi l'ultima
vita ve lo giuro
l'ultima l'ultima che sta veramente
l'ultima cosa che toccò a dai dai dai
non fare figure del delle palle buy
ma ragazzi spero che vi sia piaciuto mai
fatta scelta migliore di portare un
gioco vecchio sul mio canale proprio ho
scelto quello giusto scelto vero che ai
video vi sia piaciuto io sono stato
contentissimo di registrarlo ve lo giuro
proprio non vedo l'ora di farlo
chiedetemi di continuarlo e perché devo
farlo continuerò di certo sono già qua
già faccio secondo episodio ii dove
recita con un'impresa cavalli solamente
iscrizione sono state positive ne
citiamo ad un prossimo salto una
prossima morte tanto guarda da ragazzi